[Music]
today we cancel the dallas police
department for proudly bragging about
committing felony theft
well it would be felony theft if agents
of the state were subject to the same
laws as the rest of us as it happens
they are not which led to the to this
post from dallas pd on facebook
showing a police dog named ballentine
standing near a massive pile of cr of
cash 100 thousand dollars to be exact
and the caption of the post says
we need to get him some treats canine
officer valentine does it again on
december 2nd 2021 the love field
interdiction squad seized over a hundred
thousand dollars with the help of
valentine good job valentine
this certainly does nothing to just
dissuade my prejudice against dogs by
the way this is why cats i don't like
cats but they are superior in the end
because at least they aren't narcs they
aren't tattletails like a cat's gonna
mind their own business they see what
you're up to and they're gonna say you
know do your thing i'm doing my thing
the dog's gonna go tell on you
now you might be wondering about the
rest of the story what what crime did
this person commit
well this person a woman um didn't
commit any crime nor was she charged
with or accused of any crime what she
did was fly from chicago to dallas with
a lot of money in her luggage it is not
illegal to have your own money in your
luggage by the way that is not illegal
and yet through a little magic called
civil asset forfeiture the police can
seize your money along with any other
property it wants
without charging you with a crime
without giving you recourse to any sort
of due process
they simply take the money and that's it
this is ours now they say thank you for
your contribution
civil asset forfeiture is extremely
common and it's big business for the
state ostensibly they steal the money
because it might be connected to a crime
the problem is they don't have to prove
that it was connected to a crime or even
officially accuse you or charge you with
the crime
they can still take it and they can keep
it how do you get it back well in
practice you don't
few people ever do
due process is flipped on its head in a
civil asset forfeiture case now the
person whose property was seized must
prove that they were not committing a
crime
they must prove a negative
if they can't they're out of luck
you also
don't have the right to counsel in these
cases so if you don't have the time and
money to fight it which most people
don't then you're even more out of luck
and if you really want to fight it out
then you better be ready for the long
haul a guy named jerry johnson flew from
north carolina to phoenix to buy a truck
for his small business last year
uh he was paying in cash about forty
thousand dollars
and he brought it with him rather than
trying to withdraw the sum out of state
police at the airport took all of the
money claiming it was for drugs
but they didn't charge him with with a
drug trafficking crime because there was
no evidence of it
johnson produced documents proving that
he was trying to buy a truck but the
court said that his evidence of
innocence was insufficient
a year later in the case is just now
going to an appeals court
we should also note that in most cases
police aren't seizing massive amounts of
money
i mean they aren't even trying to take
down pablo escobar types drug kingpins
which which again ostensibly is what
what these laws are supposed to be on
the books for instead on average they
confiscate a few hundred dollars at a
time in my state tennessee the average
hall is about 500 bucks
this means that the theft victim has
little incentive to go through the
bureaucratic hell to get their property
back they'll probably lose more on the
attempted recovery than they lost in the
initial burglary
this is all as i said big business for
the government at the federal level the
justice department has massively
increased its revenue through civil
forfeitures on the local level in many
states police get to keep a hundred
percent of what they take
no conflict of interest there right
altogether the government makes billions
and billions of dollars this way
just by taking it from citizens
and that explains why there is not a
bipartisan effort to repeal these laws
on the federal level an effort that
would be extremely popular on the right
and left among almost all voters
but money is king and the government
makes a lot of money by stealing it
why would it ever give that up money
certainly trumps the constitution which
explicitly and unambiguously forbids
exactly this sort of thing you are
guaranteed the right to be free from the
seizure of property without due process
it's right there in the fifth amendment
you can look it up for yourself in fact
i'll read it for you verbatim no person
shall be deprived of life liberty or
property without due process of law nor
shall private property be taken for
public use without just compensation
civil asset forfeiture defies every
aspect of this clause your property is
taken with no due process and you're not
compensated
it would seem that this amendment must
be changed to read no person shall be
private property without due process
unless the government really really
wants to and promises they have a good
reason in which case okay fine
keep in mind as i said that there is
bipartisan support for this system from
both parties going all the way to the
top as journalist chuck modi on twitter
pointed out a very prominent politician
was a huge proponent of state-sponsored
theft for years now and and was one of
the leading figures responsible for
codifying this into law in the name of
fighting quote the war on drugs you may
recognize this guy let's watch
we change the law so that if you are
arrested and you are a drug dealer under
our forfeiture statutes
you can the government can
take everything you own
everything from your car to your house
your bank account not merely what they
confiscate in terms of the dollars from
the transaction that you've just got
caught engaging in they can take
everything
we have laws in the last several years
where we don't allow judges discretion
to sentence people
flat time sentencing
you get caught you go to jail
well
all of these tools have been at the
president's disposal for the last
hundred weeks
and more
now if america's crime problem is worse
than it ever was it's not because the
congress has failed to give the
president the tools
it's done its part but rather because
the administration has failed to use the
power given to it by the congress over
the last five years and in particular
the last 100 weeks to bring this
epidemic under control
now he meant all of that in a good way
just to clarify he was talking about the
government taking all of your stuff and
doing whatever it wants and expect us to
be grateful for it
in fact his gripe at the time was that
these these laws weren't being being
utilized enough and not enough private
property had been unconstitutionally
confiscated
how did that all work out by the way
biden
america's crime problem was worse than
it ever was in 1991 biden says then we
put all these policies in place
how are we doing now vis-a-vis the crime
problem
not too great from what i understand in
fact crime today especially violent
crime is worse than it ever was
it would seem that simply empowering the
government to engage in armed robbery
isn't a great strategy for crime
reduction at best you are shifting the
crime from private citizens to the
government
it's a kind of nationalization of theft
though you may argue that the irs
already did that
while we confront with civil asset
forfeiture is the harsh reality that the
constitution is a piece of paper
an artifact really speaking of things in
museums not a divinely self-enforcing
edict
the constitution has no power on its own
no law ever does or can it derives its
power from the respect and deference
paid to it by the human beings who run
the country but the human beings who run
our country right now have no respect or
deference for it or for any other law or
any other standard beyond their own
whims
we become then a fundamentally lawless
country because there is nothing
underpinning the actions of the state
other than the arbitrary self-serving
impulses of the individuals who comprise
it
civil asset forfeiture is not the cause
of this situation or even necessarily
the worst example of it but that is the
situation nonetheless
and that is why today not only the
dallas police department but civil asset
forfeiture is also cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated